convaincre la population russe
- Il y a quelques semaines
seulement, Volnovakha étai
gouverné par l'Ukraine.
Aujourd'hui c'est l'armée russe
qui monte la garde à l'ent
et bleu, en guise de victoire
du Kremlin, qui affirme, non p
avoir conquis la ville, mais
l'avoir libérée, pour de bon.
Libéré de qui? Libéré de quoi?
espèce d'idée, mais elle a
survécu. Elle dit que c'est pire
que la Grande guerre dans
laquelle son père s'est battu.
"À l'époque ils savaient
Aujourd'hui ce n'est pas clair.
Qu'est-ce qui nous arrive?
En quoi est-ce que ça no
concerne nous et les enfants?
C'est n'importe quoi."
totale. Aucun immeuble n'a été
épargné, même à l'école. C'est
l'armée russe qui guide notre
la ville aux termes de six
semaines de cotetetetetenses.
Ce sont les soldats russes aussi
qui décident ce que nous pouvons
voir et à qui nous pouvons
parler. Denis Pouchiline l l l e
autoproclamée de Donetsk était
là pour donner le ton.
"C'est important que ces images
diffusées et consommées parlélél
aux journalistes. En accusant
l'Ukraine de sx x x x x x x x x.
Ces deux garçons ont bel
et bien vécu ces bombardem i i t
exactement ce qui s'est passé.
"Quand on est cachés
dans un sous-sol, terrifiés,
et de où. Ça venait de tous
s,s,s,s,s,s,s, dit-il, et si cet
les nazis, c'est difficile de
comprendre leurss)s)s)s)s)s)s)s)
Mais aujourd'hui, c'est
la Russie qui les contrôle.
L'hymne national pour cette
rentrée scolaire des plus
de guerre.
ont été organisés pour montrer
que la vie continue,
que les combats s'intensifient
et se concentrent dans..........
Difficile de savoir ce
que pensent ces mères,
alors que les soldats russess'as
alentours devant les caméras.
sont parties en PologneUkUkUkUke
est dispersé."
"Les enanananananananananananas
à l'intérieur, l'angoisse
les ronge encore, dit
cette maman, le deuil aussi."
des proches, des amis
dans les combats, mais il
ne montre personne du doigt.
on s'en fout, dit Maria.
L'écvivivivivivivivivie
continue, mais mes amis ne
sont plus là. La g i i i i i i e
la couleur qu'on brandit."
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Montréa